A couple of more things about the model
that are similar to what we did
before for the Kalman, okay?
Since I know some of you have a machine
learning background a little bit
drawn here is a graphical model.
The idea is that x is only impacted by
what the x was before, and
what the new protobation is.
And the z's, the measurements, are only
a function of the current state,
all right.
And that's written in the following way,
right.
The first thing says the probability of
the measurement, given all the states,
given all my histories,
only a function of the current state and
that's sometimes called
sensor independence.
Okay, the sensing is only dependent
on the current state, all right.
The other element is this one that
says the probability of the next
state given all of these things that
came in and including the states before
is only a function of where we were
before plus the current input.
And by the way, here, this is
written as ut, not the ut minus 1,
that's what I was telling
you about before.
The shame on me,
because I did both of those and
I should have made them consistent.
But the idea,
this is the Markovian property, right?
We ha, we had the Markovian
property last time also.
And Markovian property says,
if I know the state at the last time,
none of the earlier state information,
none of the earlier measurements,
none of the earlier anything
matter except the state then.
And then the one thing we've
added new this time is action
at the current time, okay?
That's the Markovian property.